Aaron and I just saw your 5 season 1 of
rainbow succeed called void edge with
this season they're adding two new
operators and they're redoing the Oregon
map the operators are Jana a Dutch
operator and the kool-aid man he is
totally the kool-aid man let's talk
about Oryx Oryx is a man who can smash
through walls hence in the event I think
many of us were screaming oh yeah you
can call him the Hulkbuster yeah
juggernaut whatever that's his ability
he can - that - is on a cooldown timer
so you can't just do an unlimited amount
but he you know he can - close distance
or - and smash through any unreinforced
walls now he does take ten damage when
he goes through a wall and you are
stunned a little bit when you get
through so it's fairly easy for enemies
to pick you off if you don't time it
right the flip side of that is this - is
now the best way in the game to counter
shield operators so previously there's
really been no good way to do it he can
knock them down he can knock down any
character but you can knock down in
particular people like Montaigne and
then follow up and kill them while
they're on the ground the one thing to
be careful of though is that the time it
takes him to ready his gun after he
knocks someone on the ground or even
just does that charge is a while so a
couple times would have to me as I bust
through a wall and see someone and they
just see me and shoot me before I could
even react because it was taking forever
to lift his gun up he's also he's also
kind of a huge tell for attackers he's
good at like opening up walls during
preparation phases but hit the holes he
makes and walls are very obvious now is
he - yeah he's very noisy I'm like
Xavier he is a very noisy power rumor
the other thing that he has which is
actually I would say equally is bigger
or if not more important is he's a
leaper he can jump up through hatches
there's two two phases to it he jumps
and he Peaks and then he commits to
going through the hatch
but that means that you can run around
with his various weapons including his
bailiff shotgun pistol open up hatches
and climb vertical space like no other
operators so the new map Oregon in
particular he can go up two stories
whenever he wants to you just through
hatches and flank other teams through
stairwells it's definitely something
that will help him end to end rounds as
a power rumor friendlies victorious
hostile eliminated that does not have a
cool-down so he can climb through a
hatch anytime he wants what kind of guns
is yeah if he's got this past 12 I know
shotguns complement this operator pretty
well so you can knock out the hatches
and you can get up there but he also has
a submachine gun too like most people on
defense right yeah so he's got the mp5
submachine gun and he's got his fast 12
a bailiff shotgun or a USP 40 pistol we
tended to run with the mp5 to give him a
little bit of range and the day lift
shotgun pistol to open up hatches and
make murder holes that was a really good
loadout for him but yeah overall I think
he's gonna be a good alternative to calf
players he's gonna be a Power rumor and
you're really gonna have to watch your
back if you're hitting a floor he could
get above you and back around very
quickly yeah and then I played Yana a
lot Yana is a new dutch operator on
offense and her deal is that she has a
hologram she can throw down and take
control of and then she can explore the
map for a limited amount of time so it
works well as just surveillance like you
can check out the map you can see what's
going on but what we found what was
ideal was that you can run distractions
with this thing so I'd set it down
either sprint into a room everyone in
that everyone in that room would just
shoot at the hologram and then someone
else would follow in and try to sweep
from there I found that worked pretty
well it does require a good bit of
coordination but there are some things
you do have to look out for for instance
if you step on a mute jammer your
hologram will shut down if it gets shot
even once
hologram gets shut down thankfully it
does recharge though so if it does get
shot
you can give it a bit of time and you
can use it again you can use it as much
as you want from what it seems like I
definitely enjoyed her more than Oryx I
think because I think she has is gonna
have a bigger impact on the meta who
knows I could be wrong but I think the
way you can play her is super
interesting and one thing to note with
her hologram unlike alibi
it does copy your loadout so defenders
have no way of knowing whether it's her
or her hologram there are no particular
towels unless again she runs across a
mute camera or an electrified surface
it's basically a second chance she gets
to run into a room before she actually
runs into a room however you you can't
spot when you're in the hologram and you
can't shoot when you're in the hologram
yeah you can't shoot and it also doesn't
ping like if an enemy takes down that
hologram it's not like alibi where it
says where the shooter was you you're
more relying on your communication if
you run into a room you're gonna have to
tell your team where they're located
there's not a pink that'll pop up so you
have to be a little careful there in
terms of weapons she is the ARX 200 and
the g36c interestingly enough she is the
only operator other than ash that has
the g36c which I thought was pretty cool
it's nice seeing that gun being used
more then she has the mk1
nine-millimeter and then she has a
fraggin smoke the other big change with
this new season is that they are redoing
the Oregon map I kind of lukewarm on it
right now
the Oregon map was on my favorite maps
in siege I always loved when it comes up
I guess I have to play it more I think
the biggest change right now that I've
noticed is the meeting room and I think
you had more specifics on the changes
that came to that room but yeah it's
hard to say what I think about it yeah
the meeting room on Oregon was probably
what's most noticeable they got rid of
the ladder to the Attic directly over
that room kind of making it works his
territory so he's now the only defender
who can leap up into the attic which
makes him very dangerous we ended around
that way and again I think they've done
a lot of thinking around these two
operators with their Oregon redesign as
with all map redesigns it'll just take
some getting used to
you'll you'll come around some corners
and find things are different
yeah overall some interesting tweaks to
that man yeah so Aaron which one did you
prefer Oryx or Yana I'm definitely gonna
go with Oryx because I like being the
kool-aid man I I don't know if being
reckless is gonna help but it is really
fun okay that's what I noticed I try to
work a couple times and I'd bust their
wall and die I was just too reckless to
- I guess on the offense trying to mess
up people's day and I just bust the
wrong get shot
y'all honor though I really liked
because you get that second chance right
I do it way too much where I sprint into
a room and die immediately with this
hologram I can sprint into the room see
where the gunfire is and then follow up
as the real thing or maybe have a
teammate run behind me and clear the
room anyway that was void edge if you
have any comments be sure to leave them
below and stay tuned for more Rainbow
six siege
[Music]